I SHOULD HAVE STOOD UP AND
WALKED BACK, GOT IN MY CAR AND
DROVE BACK TO MY HOUSE THE
GUIDELINES ETC. THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT I AM PREACHING ALL THE TIME
WAS CONTRADICTED.
>> GAVIN NEWSOM ON THE DEFENSE
AFTER DEFINING HIS OWN COVID-19
RESTRICTIONS AND ATTENDING A
DINNER PARTY IN AN UPSCALE
RESTAURANT WITH TWO OF THE
STATE’S.MEDICAL OFFICIALS,
PHOTOS SHOW THEM WITHOUT MASKS
DESPITE THE GOVERNOR’S STATEWIDE
MASK MANDATE.
THE HYPOCRISY COULD COST NEWSOM
HIS TITLE.
MY NEXT GUEST SAYS HE’S
CONSIDERING CHALLENGING NEWSOM
IN 2022, SAN DIEGO MAYOR KEVIN
FALCONER JOINED ME NOW.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF GAVIN
NEWSOM’S ACTIONS AND HIS
APOLOGY?
>> GOOD MORNING.
I WILL TELL YOU IT IS INCREDIBLY
HYPOCRITICAL, THAT IS WHAT MAKES
SO MANY CALIFORNIANS ANGRY.
AT A TIME PEOPLE ARE BEING ASKED
TO SACRIFICE ONE OF THE WORST
ECONOMIC RECESSIONS EVER TO HAVE
THE GOVERNOR NOT PRACTICE WHAT
YOU PREACHES, GO TO ONE OF THE
MOST LAVISH EXPENSIVE RESTAURANT
IN THE COUNTRY AND BREAK HIS OWN
RULES AND EXECUTIVE ORDERS, THAT
IS NOT LEADERSHIP.
WE NEED NEW LEADERSHIP IN
SACRAMENTO.
WE NEED A GOVERNOR THAT CAN
ACTUALLY BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE NEED
RIGHT NOW.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THE
REACTION OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WILL BE TO SAY I AM NOT DOING
IT, NOT GOING TO WEAR A MASK OR
SOCIALLY DISTANCE, IF HE’S NOT
DOING IT WHY SHOULD I DO IT?
>> I AM AND SOME OTHER FOLKS ARE
AS WELL.
I’VE BEEN OUT FRONT A LOT
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING, TO WEAR THAT MASS,
PRACTICE DISTANCING, HYGIENE,
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WE WANT EVERYBODY TO BE SAFE BUT
WHEN THE GOVERNOR DOESN’T FOLLOW
HIS OWN ORDERS IT MAKES PEOPLE
NOT WANT TO FOLLOW THEM.
THE WHOLE IDEA IS THAT THERE IS
RULES FOR YOU BUT NOT FOR HIM,
NORMALLY HYPOCRITICAL BUT WORKS
AGAINST WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS KEEP
EVERYBODY HEALTHY.
IT IS A DIFFICULT TIME.
THAT IS WHY LEADERSHIP IS SO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY AS WE GO INTO THE
HOLIDAYS AND THANKSGIVING.
WE NEED LEADERSHIP THAT
DEMONSTRATES BY EXAMPLE.
JEDEDIAH: PEOPLE ARE GETTING
TIRED OF POLITICIANS NOT
PRACTICING WHAT THEY PREACH.
DO YOU FEEL THAT PEOPLE WILL BE
HOLDING HIM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THESE ACTIONS IN TERMS OF
PERHAPS VOTING FOR SOMEONE ELSE
NEXT TIME AROUND?
>> CALIFORNIANS NEED A CHANGE,
THERE ARE SO MANY ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE NOT BEING
SOLVED.
WE LOOK TO OUR SCHOOLS, WE ARE
NOT SEEING LEADERSHIP FROM THE
GOVERNOR IN SACRAMENTO AS WE SEE
HALF 1 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WAITING FOR THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT
CHECKS.
YOU CAN’T GET THE BREAKDOWN IN
OUR UNEMPLOYMENT DEPARTMENT.
WE SEE HOMELESSNESS SPIRALING
OUT OF CONTROL, SAN DIEGO COUNTY
THE ONLY COUNTY THAT IS GOING
DOWN OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS AND
I’M PROUD OF WHAT WE HAVE DONE.
THESE DIFFICULT TIMES REQUIRE
LEADERSHIP AND BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND THAT IS WHERE THIS
STATE NEEDS TO GO.